hi everyone my name is Toby busy day um
I work at a large bank I do a lot of
Java development previously did Python
development work in the credit portfolio
group so a lot of finance and technology
today i'll be sharing with you about
picasa and how to set it up along with
Cassandra so basically Cassandra in
Python so what's cassandra cassandra is
an open-source nor sequel database um
that basically means it's non-relational
and it's distributed to handle large
amounts of data across multiple servers
so um the precursors to this were big
table which is from google and also
dynamo so it merges those two
technologies what problems does it solve
in terms of storing massive amounts of
data that's very a bets a very large
strength with Cassandra it's scalable
it's also scheme allah so if your data
is unstructured you can also you know
utilize Cassandra its fault tolerant so
I talked about the distribution um if
one node goes down all your other nodes
are still working and you don't lose any
data nothing goes wrong there is no
master it's masterless um so all the
nodes can do the same work as another
node no one nerve is a central so once
again that's why if one node goes down
you're okay there's also fast retrieval
it's based on a key value data store
model so that means that your data is
indexed how do you install Cassandra so
cassandra has a website there it is
there's a tar file you just downloaded
and unzipped that's a little typo there
um you have to set up at home and
variable
environment variable and make sure you
have java java 7 specifically then
there's a yamel file that you have to
edit that's your config file you just
have to add your directories in there
and there's this link here that kind of
details it more in terms of actually a
starting Cassandra you have to go to
where cassandra is located type in this
command right there and then you'll see
a message listening to thirth clients so
I'll just demonstrate for you guys
really quickly here okay so depends it
depending on your processing power just
can take like a second or you know a
couple minutes as it is in my case
so it's doing all this background work
and then eventually we'll get this
message right here listening for thrift
clients so what is thrift what does this
mean let's look at that it's an
interface definition language and what
that is is something that describes the
software components interfaces in a
language-independent way so that there's
communication between different
languages it's kind of like I guess a
way to translate there's also in this
case between Python and Cassandra easy
access so specifically the focus here is
picasa which is a python wrapper and
it's built on top of thrift how do we
install para casa um there's a github
repo for it and you can manually install
picasa that way and i actually prefer
using kit because you're supposed to
also be able to use pip but when I
pipped installed pi cos I was it was
missing the pike house a shell so that's
what it says here in this sort of last
sublet um and a prerequisite as I
discussed before is having thrift so you
can help install that or it comes with
Continuum's manaconda distribution so
connecting to Cassandra using picasa
first you just want to check that you
properly installed picasa and one way to
do that to jury is by importing pi casa
and if you don't get any other
then it probably correctly downloaded so
now let's actually start the picasa
shell you go to the directory or it's
located and then you just type in the
short command python picasa so let's do
that so once again this is dependent on
processing power take a few minutes ok
there we go so Cassandra interactive
Python shell what does that mean it's
basically ipython and if you are
familiar with ipython you'll notice that
it already kind of looks like ipython
with the in one moving on so there's
this whole idea of key spaces and column
families in Cassandra so in picasa we
want to type up these commands that i
have a screenshot of so we're creating
our key space in the first in the first
line then we're creating our column
family and so these are the things that
we only need to do once here i have
dummy key spaces i called in key space
one column family one dummy calm family
and then we have to actually here's
where we're really connecting with
Python so this is every time you open up
picasa you wouldn't have to do this but
just just once um so what is a key space
it's similar to a schema in a relational
database so that they basically just
group columns together and calm families
excuse me and what is a column family
it's similar to a table a table from a
relational database
so I talked about schemas I think I said
that Cassandra schema-less so what is a
schema exactly in a non relational
database typically you well you must if
not typically you must define predefine
your columns and your data types in
Cassandra that's optional and you
probably actually would want to just add
that schema anyway if your data does
have structure it's easier to just have
that you know availability or ability to
add a schema and so even though we have
this idea of a schema and Cassandra the
storage engine is different so that it's
it's still very very unlike a relational
database for instance here we're looking
at example of a schema and Cassandra we
can notice that there's there's this
whole area where there are no there's no
data it doesn't even say it doesn't say
no it's just empty so that's a big
difference because these nulls do take
up space in a relational database
whereas here were were okay with not
filling that area up and that adds to
Cassandra sufficiency so there's a
sparse column engine space is only used
by the collins present so this whole
birth date column isn't present and the
third and fourth row we're not going to
not going to fill it fill that up with
anything um so I was mentioned that it's
recommended to create a schema if you do
have structured data um there's a blog
on datastax that kind of tells details
more about Cassandra's schema structure
if you want to find out more but here
we're just adding data that's what the
screenshot is so I talked about the key
space which is like the schema
and the column family so once that's
created here I'm inserting dummy data
this first row with and here you can
also see the column the key value
structure coming in but so this is just
inserting a row of data right here
that's what this shows and what we get
out is actually a binary object however
we can't actually retrieve that so right
here is a command there's a method get'
which allows us to retrieve that data
that we just put in there are similar
numbers of commands in picasa like get
count different methods similar to what
you would see in a relational database
so there's a lot of crossover there more
raised in this link I provided there so
I said I would get more into nodes and
what they are their servers that help
distribute and replicate the data um and
together they form a cluster with
varying topologies what we have to do if
these are physicals we have to assign
each server or each node a unique token
so that we can figure out what data is
being stored there so if we go back to
the schema that I pointed out before
basically this first column right here
would be the primary key and then within
that you would have um you would have
basically like replication keys so
there's just a way to divide all your
data and assign that to a specific node
and so a row name in each in column I'm
losing my cursor so like maybe we
pick this as our replication key and
that would help us fit help the new
figure out of which data is going where
what it's replicating um whoops sorry um
okay so the next thing is um oh ok so
here there's just a link i forgot to
mention this is just a link with how you
can set up a cluster in Cassandra to
learn more ok so you know this isn't
actually necessary to do until you
actually you know need to add more
memory to your cluster you have more
data you need to add and you've
completely exhausted your your current
server your first machine which is your
seed however so I talked about this
whole idea of having tokens and needing
to assign each note a token but if you
use virtual nodes you don't actually
have to do that so it's easier to manage
there's this whole idea of rebalancing
and that's gone when you're using
virtual nodes so I guess I'm a little
finger they have a little bit more time
on any questions
well actually yeah this um was motivated
by something I was doing at work where
we were having trouble with queries
taking too long and just um having too
much data because this is you know when
you have like terabytes petabytes of
data something like this that scales
well is and you don't have to change the
schema is a lot more convenient so I was
playing around with this yeah work any
other question
position you're saying oh all right yeah
yeah definitely yeah you can do that
that's the whole idea of the schema so
you can pre define the data types yeah
and pandas are saying there are
duplicate columns yeah the whole on fact
that it doesn't actually store um it
doesn't store like wrote it doesn't
store like you know it doesn't store all
columns so for instance like here like
rose three and four I was saying that we
don't we don't need to put anything
there not even a null so uh with this
comes the fact that we're actually we're
replicating for column names
oh that's what you're saying okay know
that those would be unique I believe so
any other questions Fred all right um so
I I didn't really talk about the whole
cql but on an alternative to thrift
which is basically what picasa is it's
using thrift to communicate with
Cassandra you can use what is called
Cassandra Korean language and it's
basically like sequel um so the things I
talked about the different commands like
here we're inserting or we're counting
you know like that there's an analogous
version of that arm called cql it it's
very similar to SQL so I think if you're
coming from relational background it
might be easier for you to kind of like
adapt to Cassandra if you were using cql
so that is an alternative to picasa
that's good point
hmm to query well what do you mean by
run the whole system oh you mean like
doing data analysis more like that well
it definitely would be a lot faster like
and you're talking about just what did
you say 1 gigabyte or something I don't
know what you said but you know but
something like that it's definitely not
you know milliseconds or something even
faster I haven't actually timed any of
these things but um you know really the
strength of cassandra is when you do
have those really large sets of data and
even with that i mean you know with more
data you would have more servers more
nodes in your cluster and you do lose a
little bit of speed with on in terms of
querying and returning data but it's not
the same as for instance with a
relational database where they're really
would be a bottleneck
well so I actually was just exploring
this we didn't actually implement this
at my job but I know Facebook uses it I
think Amazon uses it on some other major
companies but like really rely on this
but I mean I would say you know if
you're dealing with massive amounts of
data that would be a good use case for
exploring Cassandra you had a question
right um yeah you could use pip on Mac
um but in terms of installing like
actually that was actually so sort i
showed you connecting to it um we're
starting the I should starting the
starting Cassandra and Windows but
installing it is the same is really the
same process on any operating system
you're unzipping the files and you can
you know doesn't matter what operating
system you're on you can unzip files
setting up home environments on this
link is window specific so how you would
get to where your home environments are
might be different and on a Mac but you
know the same ability as possible
editing config files that's just me
opening an editor and I'm typing and
correcting i'm typing stuff in so um you
know every operating system has editors
so yeah this would be this actually this
part wouldn't I don't foresee that being
an issue and i don't i believe the
command isn't different either for
starting Cassandra this bin Cassandra I
believe it does apply for 40 s 44 max
I like MongoDB that's a good question
and um whoops so um I once all kind of
like a graph comparing it to because
compare and Cassandra to things like
[ __ ] and basically when I was talking
about sort of like the reasons you would
want to use Cassandra scalability fast
retrieval on some of the other new
sequel databases they're not as easily
scalable for instance because they're
different I also talked about the key
value store model there are different
models underneath various no sequel
databases so um that affects something
like the ability to retrieve data or um
usually though I believe that they do
all have on they do all the no sequel
databases do all function with a node
cluster type idea it's just that you
know how do you actually like implement
that idea here and Cassandra it's
masterless so um I'm not you know
exactly sure about [ __ ] but that's one
area may be other no not no sequel
databases do you have a master in there
clustered anything else okay well end it
a little early but thank you